Guten Abend. Guten Abend.
Polat ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Erstentätig,
wo ich gerne mit ihnen ein Anameser-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Abend. Hallo. Wie heißen Sie bitte nochmal?
Mein Nachname ist Polat.
Polat, das ist aber kein deutschen Name, oder?
Natürlich, ja.
Kein deutschen Name?
Kein deutschen Name.
Ah, wo kommen Sie?
Können die Zutaten auch studieren? Sind Sie auch Ärztin?
Ja, ich habe meine Studie abgeschlossen.
Dann arbeite ich in Deutschland.
Warum sind Sie da?
Nach Deutschland?
Ja, ich will meinen Beruf hier ausüben.
Ah, dann herzlich willkommen. Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Glück, Frau Dr.
Dankeschön.
Jetzt, bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen,
möchte ich Ihren aktuellen persönlichen Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Heinrich Krause.
Können Sie bitte eher Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Das haben Sie doch schon vorgelegt bekommen.
Ich habe mich doch schon angemeldet, Frau Dr.
Warum fragen Sie mich das noch mal?
Ja, ich muss Ihnen nochmal diese Frage stellen.
Doch, ich komme hier bei dem Thema.
Um die Wahrheit zu sichern.
Wahrheit zu sichern?
Ja, oder zur Sicherheit.
Ach so, okay. Sie möchten die Daten nochmal kontrollieren.
Heinrich, Hans, Emil, Ida, Nordpol,
Ida, Caesar, Heinrich.
Ich habe nicht gehört. Können Sie bitte nochmal ustabilieren?
Noch mal? Bin ich zu leise?
Ja, manchmal ist Ihre Stimme weg, deswegen konnte ich nicht.
Moment, vielleicht liegt es an meinem Telefon,
aber sollte eigentlich gut, ist es jetzt besser?
Ja.
Also, Heinrich, Hans, Emil, Ida, Nordpol,
Richard, Ida, Caesar, Heinrich.
Ja, Nachname?
Krause, Kar, Erwe, Richard.
Ja.
Arviantum, Esz, Siegfried und Ewe.
Krause.
Ja.
Herr Krause. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Krause?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Das wollen Sie auch noch wissen.
Ich bin geboren, 28. Mai 1960.
Okay, wie viel wiegen Sie?
86 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ist das wichtig, Frau Doktor? Wollen Sie das jetzt noch wissen?
Ja, ich muss diese Autodaten erfahren.
Was wollten Sie jetzt noch mal wissen?
Was sind Ihre Größe, frage ich.
Ach, meine Größe.
Wie groß ich bin? 1,83 m.
Okay.
Herr Krause, was für die Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich für Sie helfen?
Herr Krause, wie geht es Ihnen?
Frau Doktor, wie ist Ihre Nachname?
Polat.
Meine Frau schickt mich.
Ich habe vor einer Stunde meinen Kaffee getrunken.
Plötzlich ist mir aus der rechten Hand die Tasse aus der Hand gefallen.
Ich konnte auch nicht mehr richtig trinken.
Der Kaffee ist am Mundwinkel ausgelaufen.
Ich konnte nicht richtig schlucken.
Auch das Sprechen.
Jetzt geht es im Moment besser, aber das Sprechen ist viel mehr schwer.
Später habe ich gemerkt, dass auch mein rechter Arm ganz schwach ist in meiner Hand.
Das habe ich immer noch so ein bisschen.
Meine Frau hat mich sofort hergeschickt.
Sie hat Angst bekommen.
Ich dachte, das ist nichts Besonderes, aber meine Frau ist halt unbedingt, dass ich komme.
Sie haben gut gemacht, um zu uns zu gehen.
Haben diese Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen oder eher langsam?
Ja, das war, wie gesagt, vor einer Stunde.
Ganz plötzlich.
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich habe ein paar Erkrankungen, aber das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Wie lange dauert diese Beschwerden?
Wie gesagt, vor einer Stunde hat es angefangen.
Ich habe circa eine halbe Stunde angehalten.
Das ist ein bisschen besser geworden, aber ich habe das Gefühl, es fängt jetzt wieder an.
Es wird wieder ein bisschen schlimmer.
Jetzt aber können Sie gut sprechen?
Das Sprechen geht wieder besser, aber ich fühle so eine Taubheit.
Das ist ganz komisch.
Der Arm ist auch ganz komisch.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass er jetzt auch das Bein etwas schwach ist.
Beim Laufen habe ich gemerkt, dass es nicht so gut geht.
Ja, es gibt Kraftlosigkeit in Arm und in Bein.
Ich würde sagen, ja.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein.
Ich fand es am Anfang jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Sind Sie eh schon schwindelig?
Mir ja.
Haben Sie Feber oder Stülfros?
Ja, bisher war ich gar nicht gesund.
Ich habe gar nichts.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder Kalten Schweiz?
Schweiß, nein.
Ich bin Handwerkler, bin Schweiß, gewohnt, arbeite ganz hart.
Aber in der Nacht schwitze ich nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, ich bin immer gleich geblieben.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Übelkeit.
Nein, das ist mir nicht.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, Herr Bitt, gerade ich mir sage, Frau Doktor, wie oft müssen Sie die Frage stellen?
Sie wiederholen sich immer die ganze Zeit.
Ja, aber ich muss diese Beschwerden noch fragen.
Aber Sie stellen immer die gleichen Frage, die immer die gleichen Frage.
Nein, ich habe noch nicht gefragt.
Jetzt werde ich erst mal fragen.
Ja, dann fragen Sie bitte.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Maserlasten und Stubank?
Was hat das jetzt damit zu tun?
Ich habe keine Probleme gehabt.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, durchzuschlafen?
Mit dem Schlafen?
Ja.
Meine Frau schneicht manchmal.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie das Bewusstsein verlor?
Ja, oder vor 1 Stunden.
Als das aufgetreten ist?
Ja.
Herr Heinrich.
Herr Krause ist mein Nachnamer.
Ich möchte unsere Gespräche unterbrechen, damit ich Ihre vitalen Parameter messen.
Was sind die Vita-Parameter?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ich möchte EKG schreiben.
Okay.
Messen Sie auch den Blutdruck?
Am Ende des Gesprächs.
Nicht gleich.
Ich dachte, Sie machen das mit dem EKG gleich.
Blutdruck messen.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir weitermachen.
Ich habe ein Hausarzt gesagt, ich habe Rhythmusstörungen vor 2 Monaten.
Ich habe einen Namen vergessen.
Aber er sagte, das Herz ist unregelmäßig.
Ich merke das nicht.
Er wollte unbedingt, dass ich Medikamente zum Blut verdünnen nehme.
Aber ich wollte das nicht.
Warum?
Es könnte aspirin oder ISS sein?
Nein, da wollte man andere Medikamente zum Blut verdünnen geben.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Er meinte, das ist ganz wichtig bei der Rhythmusstörung.
Kein Problem.
Ich kann Ihnen Hausarzt fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Eierkrankungen, außer Herz-Rhythmusstörungen?
Also ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck.
Er ist manchmal auch etwas entgleist.
Ich habe auch Zucker.
Seit wann haben diese Krankheiten?
Auch schon länger.
Der Blutdruck geht schon ca. 15 Jahre.
Und der Diabetes, man hat das angefangen vor 7 Jahren.
Seit 7 Jahren.
Ihr seid ihr Blutdruck gut eingestellt?
Also wurden Sie eine ehrliche Antwort?
Natürlich.
Ich nehme meine Medikamente nicht immer regelmäßig.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie heißen.
Sie nehmen Medikamente gegen Blutdruck.
Aber noch weitere Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ja, für den Zucker.
Erinnern Sie welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Meine Frau bereitet die Medikamente für mich.
Das ist ein großes Medikament.
Das schlückt man immer sehr schwer.
Das nehme ich immer morgens.
Ich habe noch eine kleine Rose an das Runde.
Medikamente.
Das könnte passen.
Das stimmt.
Aber wie das andere heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Herr Grause.
Allegen habe ich auf Schmerzmedikamente.
Noch andere?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Allergen.
Sind Sie früher schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe schon einige Operationen hinter mir.
Da ich ein Handwerker bin, habe ich einige Verletzungen.
Welche Operationen?
Ich habe auch eine Verletzungen.
Es war einmal in den Leisten her, auf der rechten Seite.
Dann ist auch meine Gallenblase entfernt worden.
Meine Mandel sind als Kind schon entfernt worden.
Ich hatte einen Bruch am rechten Handgelenk.
Das war noch.
Und mein Knie auf der linken Seite ist operiert worden.
Okay.
Was habe ich denn?
Ist es etwas Schlimmes oder nicht?
Wie lange wollen Sie noch fragen?
Ihr Beschwäldern könnte natürlich lebensbetrachtlich sein.
Aber ich...
Ich versuche jetzt so schnell, wenn Sie mich fragen.
Dann werde ich sofort die Untersuchung durchführen.
Beeilen Sie sich bitte.
Meine Frau hat mich extra jetzt hierher gebracht,
weil sie Angst hatte und sie fragen und fragen und fragen.
Ja, ich muss erst mal diese Frage stellen,
um andere Diagnose auszuschließen.
Rauen Sie?
Ja, ich brauche.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauen Sie?
Oh, ich komme schon auf eine Packung ungefähr pro Tag.
Seit wann rachen Sie?
Seit ich 15 bin.
Okay.
Enttündeten Sie Alkohol?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie?
Auch, dass es nicht viel ist.
Nur ein bis zwei Bier am Tag.
Und abends gerne mal so einen Wein zu essen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Drogen?
Glauben Sie, ich bin Ihr Drogenhändler oder was?
Nein, Gottes Willen, Frau Dr.
Okay.
Herr Krause.
Sind Arbeiter in, sind,
sind, Sie sind Handwerker.
Haben Sie geernt?
Ich bin Handwerker, ja.
Ja.
Sind Arbeiter schon oder?
Ja, ich arbeite noch natürlich.
Bis zu Rente dauert es doch ein bisschen, Frau Dr.
Einfach geht das nicht.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich bin mit meiner Frau gekommen.
Okay.
Ihr habt unsere Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine Tochter.
Wollen Sie alleine oder in Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, ich möchte auch mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja, ja.
Ja, meine, ich muss schnell zu Ende gehen.
Leben Ihre noch?
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern?
Nee, leider nicht, die sind schon beide verstorben, ja.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Meine Mutter hatte Brustknüpps.
Und mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, ja.
Okay.
Herr Krauser, ich möchte zurück Ihre Beschwerden kommen,
dann sofort Sie eine City durchführen.
Was ist ein CT?
CT ist eine wild gebenen Untersuchung.
Die Mittel von Strahlen, Ihre Kopfgut darstellen.
Gott, wird jetzt mein Kopf bestrahlt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Was soll das bringen?
Was möchten Sie damit erreichen?
Was wollen Sie bestrahlen? Mein Kopf bestrahlen? Warum?
Weil Ihre Probleme in Ihrem Gehirn sein können.
Und muss ich, müssen wir diese Ursache herausfinden?
Ja, gibt es da keine anderen Möglichkeiten aus?
Ja, wir haben andere Möglichkeiten und eine Magnetradiosentomographie.
Aber beide Untersuchungen zeigen verschiedene...
Also ich möchte die untersuchen, wo man keine Bestrahlung bekommt.
Diese, ja, ich verstehe, die Risiken.
Aber Magnetradiosentomographie dauert länger.
Aber wir müssen schnell sein.
Ich möchte Ihnen oberatisch sprechen, Frau Doktor.
Ich glaube, Sie verstehen Ihr Handwerk nicht so gut.
Ich bin doch hier kein... Versuchskaninchen.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gündus. Ich bin oberars.
Ah, Sie scheinen einen.
Ja, wir haben einen Stroh im Lisetsfenster.
City und Bescheid geben.
Ich habe eine Frage. Haben Sie Allergien gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder Kontrastmitteln?
Nein, habe ich schon vorhin gesagt, Allergien habe ich keine, Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, unsere Arzt, ein EKG schreiben und Saustoff messen und Gemessenblutdruck ist erhöht.
Und wir müssen...
Und sehen Sie auch die Rhythmusstörung im EKG?
Ja, und Rhythmusstörung, das heißt, Vorhock-Filmen.
Ja, das stimmt. Das hat in meiner Hauswahl geblieben.
Vorhock-Filmen und Geben, wir müssen ein Medikament her.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir sind unser allesgute Team.
Okay.
Wenn Sie das so sagen, Herr Oberarzt, dann glaube ich Ihnen, dann können wir das gerne machen.
Dankeschön. Tschüss.
Schön, dass Sie da waren.
Ja, entscheidend.
Herr Oberarzt hat gesagt, das ist in Ordnung. Dann mache ich natürlich die Untersuchung.
Okay. Ich habe auf einer Seite alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Wenn wir während der CT-Cop-Untersuchung durchführen, können Sie danach Ihre Frage stellen.
Aber nehmen Sie mir auch Blut ab?
Natürlich, aber nach der CT-Untersuchung nehme ich Blut ab und körparellisch untersuchen.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut, dann machen wir die CT-Untersuchung. Kommt das gleich oder muss ich jetzt noch ein bisschen warten?
Ja, wenn die CT-Cop-Untersuchung ist.
Nein, wann ist das CT? Jetzt gleich oder?
Jetzt gleich, weil das ist eine dringende Stass.
Okay, gut. Dann warte ich hier. Alles klar.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ja, ich habe noch Fragen.
Okay, alles klar.
Keine Fragen.
Vielleicht haben Sie eine See-Störung?
See-Störungen hatte ich die letzten Tage. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber das ist wieder weggegangen.
Welche Tag oder hier, was?
Letzte Woche.
Letzte Woche und vor zwei Tagen.
Zum Beispiel Herr Kreize, heute...
Heute habe ich keine See-Störungen gehabt. Nein.
Heute war das mit dem, mit diesem, dass der Kaffee ausgelaufen ist.
Mundwinkel?
Aus dem Mundwinkel, genau.
Der Patient hat erwähnt den Mundwinkel.
Ja, und dass ich nicht richtig sprechen konnte.
Aber so Kopfschmerzen haben Sie sowas gesagt?
Ich habe nicht ganz genau verstanden.
War das Schmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen? Nein.
Orientation.
Ist der Patient orientiert?
Ist der Patient orientiert zum Ort, zur Zeit und zur Person?
Das stimmt.
Frau Doktor, was vermuten Sie?
Wollen Sie gleich die Oberarztübergabe machen?
Ja.
Wir können anfangen.
Dann liegen Sie mal los.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Frau Doktor, das ist sehr schön.
Erzählen Sie mal, was haben Sie für einen Patient?
Der Patient heißt Heinrich Krause.
Er ist 62 Jahre alt und 86 kg schwer.
Und 1,83 m groß.
Der Patient stellt sich bei uns vor 1 Stunde bestehend.
Rechthand, Paradiesie.
War das nur die Hand, oder war das Arm und Bein?
Ja, Rechte, Rechte halb viertausend.
Wie nennt sich das?
Hemiplegie.
Er hat eine rechtseitige Hemiplegie.
oder ist es eine Hemiparesis? Was hat er? Hat er eine Hemiparesis oder eine Hemiplegie?
Hemiparesis.
Das klären wir nachher nochmal, was es ist. Okay.
Als er kommt, in eine rechtsseitige Hemiplegie. Okay.
Das heißt, er hat eine Schwäche am rechten Arm, rechtes Bein.
Ja. Wegen vor Einschutung, wir stehen der rechtsseitige Hemiplegie und rechtsseitige fascial Paralysi.
Fascial Paralysi, passt aber nicht so ganz. Das ist fascial Paralysi.
Das kann passieren, aber okay, ja, können wir noch mal diskutieren.
Die Beschwerden seien...
Was hat er noch? Hat er auch eine Afarese?
Ja, der Patient berichtet, dass er auch Afaresi haben.
haben?
Diese Beschwerden seien plötzlich aufgetreten.
Der Patient habe auch Zerechtörungen.
Früher ähnliche Beschwerden haben,
haben dieser Patient wurde verneint.
Also jetzt muss ich mal das Satz richtig machen.
Der Patient habe früher keine ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Der Patient hatte ähnliche Beschwerden früher verneint.
Der Patient hatte früher keine ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Okay.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Sicher? Was war der Blutdruck?
Der Obarzt hat vorhin gesagt, bei der EKG.
Ich möchte diese Probleme in Vorerkrankungen erwähnen.
Aber das ist doch sein akutes Problem.
Der hat auch einen entgleisten Blutdruck.
Ja, er klagt da überall Artilielle Hypertonie ins Gleis.
Was haben die für einen Blutdruck gemessen?
Sie haben doch EKG gemacht und Blutdruck gemessen.
Der war doch sehr hoch.
Wie hoch war der Herr Dr. Gündus, der Blutdruck?
Der Herr Dr. Gündus hat gesagt, der Blutdruck ist sehr hoch.
190 oder 200 zu 100?
200 ist 100.
200 zu 100.
Also das heißt, der Blutdruck ist entgleist.
Und wir haben im EKG.
Was war eine Rückmusstörung?
Vorhoff für die Mann.
Wie ist der Puls?
Hat er eine Tachiaritmie oder war es ein normalverquenter Aritmie?
Tachiaritmie ungefähr 110.
Okay, gut.
Sehr gut. Also der Patient hat eine Blutungentglasung,
er hat eine Tachiaritmie.
Er bringt also alle Symptome mit.
Sehr gut.
Gut, weiter?
Ja, wie gesagt, vor Äkrankungen sind Arteriehypertone,
Vorhoffelmann und Diabetes mellitus bekannt.
Der Patient nehme ein paar Medikamente
eingenommen über Bluthochgluck und Herz.
Der Satz muss man es richtig machen.
Der Patient nimmt ein paar Medikamente
oder habe ein paar Medikamente genommen?
Nimmt ein paar Medikamente ein.
Welche Medikamente sind das?
Der Patient konnte sich nicht erinnern.
Okay, das heißt, Sie werden nachher die Ehefrau oder Frage
für den Haushalt gelesen?
Ja, ich werde sie seine Ehefrau erfahren.
Befragen, okay.
Gut.
Als er hat Medikament für den Blutdruck, was hat er noch?
Er nehme er gegen Bluthochdruck.
Vorhoffelmann und Diabetes, ein paar Medikamente.
Okay.
Hat er auch eine Antikorbulation gehabt?
Ja, eine Blutverdünne oder eine Antikorbulation.
Hat er gehabt oder nicht?
Ich glaube, der Patient hat gesagt, er hat keinen Blutverdünne.
Keine Antikorbulanz.
Ich habe nicht regelmäßig.
Der Patient hat gesagt, der Hausarzt wollte ihm eine Blutverdünnung geben.
Aber der Patient wollte das nicht.
Er nimmt andere Medikamente, die nimmt er sehr unregelmäßig.
Also es ist ein sehr inkomplayender Patient.
Und Blutverdünnung hat er abgelehnt.
Also er hat keine Antikorbulation.
Ist Aspirin eine Antikorbulation?
Nein, das ist eine Blutblättsinhemmung.
Sehr gut.
Es ist ein Antitrombozytenhemmer.
Richtig.
Das ist keine Antikorbulanz.
Markomar ist ein Antikorbulanz, aber wir reden gleich darüber.
Wir machen weiter. Was hat der Patient noch?
Der Patient wehrgilt allergisch auf Noargin.
Anfohrerkrankungen sind Leichtinherni, OP und Colossus Tectomy,
Thonsylectomy und Operationen gegen Kniegelenk und Handgelenk bekannt.
Nicht gegen Kniegelenk, sondern Operationen am Kniegelenk und am Handgelenk.
Der Patient rauchert täglich Einpackungssigarette seit 50 Jahren.
Seit wie? Seit dem?
Seit 15.
Seit dem 15.10. Lebensjahr.
Er trinkt täglich ein oder zwei Fläche Bier.
Soll es nochmals? Oder ist es nur das Bier?
Manchmal trinken Wein.
Okay. Also er trinkt weichlich Bier.
Der Patient ist Handwerker, ist verheiratet, habe eine Tochter.
Er lebt mit ihrer Familie zusammen.
Mit seiner Familie zusammen?
Mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Anfohrerkrankungen ist sein Vater an Myokarteinfarktus
und seine Mutter an Mammakarsen gestorben.
Das sind aber keine Vorerkrankungen des Patienten.
Das ist jetzt Familienanamnese.
Entschuldigung, ja. Was habe ich gesagt?
Ich habe gesagt, Anfohrerkrankungen ist der Vater.
An in der Familienanamnese.
Sehr gut, genau.
Sind Sie ein bisschen aufgeregt, Frau Doktor?
Genau.
Ich bin aufgeregt.
Brauchen Sie nicht.
Okay.
Der Patient habe eine gesunde Bruder.
Gut, das war eine sehr ausführliche Anamnese.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose, Frau Kollegin?
Oder Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose?
Ja, nach bisherigen Angehörigen gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf Schlaganfall aus.
Wie ist der medizinische Begriff dafür?
Apoplexe.
Was war ein Apoplex?
Linksseitige.
Was ist linksseitig oder linkshirnig?
Linkshirnige.
Okay, also linkszerebrale Insult.
Warum linkshirnig oder linkszerebral?
Weil die linkshirnige Apoplexe kommt zu der rechten Seite.
Was ist hemmiplegi?
Linksseitige hemmiplegi.
Führt zu einer rechtsseitigen Hemmiplegi oder Hemmiparesi.
Was hat er noch?
Was ist die Ursache?
Der Patient hat viele risikofaktoren.
Natürlich hat vorhoffeliman,
könnte eine Trombusverschluss der Gefäße im Gegensatz.
Ein tromboembolischer Verschluss?
Tromboembolischer Verschluss.
Können Perursachen, Apoplexe Perursachen.
Was war noch mit dem Glutdruck?
Ja, auch Risikofaktoren sind
unangestellte Arterielehipatoni.
Und jetzt hat er einen entgleisten Glutdruck, mit 200 zu 100.
Da kann man einen Schlaganfall bekommen.
Was hatte noch?
Risikofaktoren haben Sie gesagt?
Auch die Abethesmeilitus.
Auch Rauchelochelochel.
Er hat sehr viele kardiovaskuläre Risikofaktoren.
Man kann sagen, er hat ein metabolisches Syndrom.
Ja, metabolisches.
Wunderbar.
Können wir ein bisschen diskutieren.
Das war sehr gut.
Sie sind ein bisschen aufgeregt gewesen.
Sie sind ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Sie müssen bei den Sätzen aufpassen wegen Grammatik und wegen der Zeit.
Aber ich glaube, das ist die Nervosität.
Wenn ich aufgeregt bin,
ich finde, ich setze falsche Sätze.
Sehr gut.
Der Patient hat einen linkshirnigen Apoplex.
Sie sind Fachärztin?
Aktuell?
Nein, ich habe keine Fachbereich.
Wo haben Sie gearbeitet?
Ich konnte nicht arbeiten.
Ich bin Praktizierende.
Das ist ein Apoplex.
Vielleicht wird man bei der Prüfung,
welche Sorten von Apoplex gibt es.
Tromboembolischen oder
chemischen Insult.
Was die Ursache ist,
Blutrogendkleisung, Vorhofflemmen,
metabolische Syndrom, das können alles Symptome sein.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Hemiplegie und Hemiparesis.
Bis zum nächsten Wochen nachschauen.
Hemiparesis ist leichter.
Das ist andersherum.
Ich leise.
Ich glaube, Hemiparesis ist komplett.
Schlafe Arm, Schlafe Bein.
Hemiplegie ist nicht so.
Aber der Unterschied zwischen Hemiparesis und Hemiplegie.
Das kann sein, dass man in der Prüfung das auch noch mal fragt.
Hemiplegie ist total Kraftlosigkeit.
Hemiplegie?
Ja.
Hemiparesis ist ein bisschen Lärmung.
Aber nicht total.
Ich habe das verwechselt.
Entschuldigung, dann nehme ich alles zurück.
Ich habe gedacht, Hemiparesis ist das andere.
Super.
Was war noch?
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen?
Was braucht man bei der Prüfung von Antikorvulation?
Sie haben gesagt, Markumar.
Das ist aber eine alte Medikation.
Es gibt jetzt neue Antikorvulanzien.
Die heißen NOAC.
Wie heißen die?
Das ist Eliquis.
Es gibt auch andere Antikorvulanzien.
Das sind die Zeneriven.
Das braucht man bei Vorhofflemmand.
Das ist aspirin.
Es hilft nicht.
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen?
Es ist ja ein Lise-therapie.
Wenn man eine Computertomographie macht,
oder eine Gefäßdarstellung,
und man weiß, welches Gefäß verschlossen ist,
und kein anderes Risiko besteht,
Lüse wird schwierig.
Hoch, hoch, aber bei 200. Ja, 200. Genau. Das heißt, man wird erst mal in der Blutung
sinken und vielleicht dann eine Lüse machen. Aber in welcher Zeit kann man eine Lüse machen?
Wie lange ist die Zeitspanne? Bis vier und sechs Stunden. Genau, vier bis sechs Stunden.
Genau, deswegen ist es ganz wichtig, dass man beim Verdacht auf Schlaganfall, wie beim Herzinfarkt,
sehr schnell in die Klinik geht. Und dann hat man mit der Lüse noch sehr gute Möglichkeiten,
den Schaden abzuwenden oder einen kleinen Schaden zu haben. Ich habe eine Frage,
wenn wir einen Verdacht auf Schlaganfall haben, müssen wir das an einem sehr unterbrechen oder
bis zu Ende gehen? Das ist eine Prüfung. Vielleicht schaut man als erstes nach dem Vitalparameter,
das heißt Blutdruck, EKG und Sauerstoffwettigung. Und wenn das in Ordnung ist, dann kann man,
sag ich mal, eine Alamnese relativ schnell machen. Ich meinte, zum Beispiel City und Teilsuchung.
Nee, City kann man sich zeigen, weil sie haben vier Stunden Zeit,
je nachdem. Wenn der Patient sagt, das Ganze war jetzt vor einer Stunde, dann haben sie ein
bisschen Zeit. Und der Patient, wenn es ihm im Moment gut geht, das heißt, er ist cardiopulmonatstabil,
er ist nicht bewusstlos, er hat einen guten Kreislauf, dann können sie natürlich erst
einmal die Alamnese fertigen machen. Wenn er aber instabil ist, das heißt, wenn er Blutdruck
entgleist ist, wenn er vielleicht nicht ansprechbar ist, die Kollege hat gemeint,
wie ist das mit der Orientierung, wenn er nicht ansprechbar ist, nicht sprechen kann.
Und Sie merken, da ist in einem instabilen Zustand, dann mache ich natürlich erst mal die
Untersuchung und versuche, wenn ich Anzeichen habe für einen Schlaganfall, versuche natürlich
relativ schnell eine CT-Untersuchung zu machen. Okay. Und welche Fragen musste ich stellen?
Ja, das war schon ganz gut, Sie hätten freischalgen müssen. So eine grob neurologische
Untersuchung, in dem man schaut, welche Arm ist schwach, wie ist die Kraft, wie ist die,
wie ist die Parästhesie oder hat der Parästhesien, neurologische Störungen,
ist es nur die Kraft oder hat auch Gefühlsstörungen, das kann man schnell machen. Und wie ist die
Schwäche, ist es nur im Arm oder ist es Arm und Bein oder ist es die gesamte rechte Seite.
Das muss man vielleicht anschauen, um zu orientieren, wie groß der Schlaganfall ist.